Alright folks welcome back. So this lesson is going to be a little bit shorter more
direct to the point and we'll be looking at some examples since I showed you what
we're looking for on Tuesday night. So Wednesday's trading and Thursday's
trading. We'll take a look at that. Alright first up is the e-mini S&P March
delivery contract for 2022. Wednesday January 26th. Why don't you take a look at this
low over here. Okay and don't just use my charts. You want to look at your charts
and go through it from your platform, your broker, whatever feed that you're
using. This is trading view. It's a free charting package when it's end of data
but if you want to have real time I think I'm paying four dollars a month
for the data. It's not really expensive but you want to have the low over here
on Wednesday the 26th and you'll see why I picked that low there because it's the
low. Okay and then this is the high. So we have this price run from this low to
this high. That's our range. So you want to drop your fib on that. Now get your
equilibrium price point. So as the highs were ran through we had that run up. The
market gets pushed into a premium. It's really expensive and then we want to
wait to see does it break down below the old high. It does but does it create a
fair value gap in here? No. Then it rallies one more time then breaks down
again. Inside here there's a break in market structure. We see it here then it
runs back up into the fair value gap here and then sells off reaching into
this old low which would be below the equilibrium price point of this entire
range or 50% level on the fib. Okay put some lipstick on this. Again here's the
low and the high equilibrium which is a 50 level on the Fibonacci. So we're
looking for a low or an imbalance below this level. Okay so we have a swing low
here. We have an imbalance here that could be a target. Notice how we hit it
there and came off of it. More pronounced low here and draws down into that. So
inside this shaded blue area we're gonna take a closer look at the details. Okay
we're zoomed in a little bit. Again still on a two-minute chart. Previous high,
short-term high and 830 in the morning. That starts the hunt basically. That's
what 830 in the morning is to me. So we're looking for an old high to be
violated. It does so here. Then it breaks. There's a break in market structure.
Swing low. This candle over here that sets the stage. Now you have a
opportunity. Does price draw back up into the fair value gap after this candle
breaks below here and giving you a bearish market structure shift. Yes it
trades up into that fair value gap. You can go short there and again you could
target this old low here or that low that was annotated before we zoomed in
and look at the beautiful delivery there. So hypothetical short from here
and hypothetical cover here. You would log that in your study journal. Don't use
my examples here alone. Go into your own charts and annotate them as well. So
shorting around we'll say 4419 and covering at we'll say 4382 just to be
you know not perfect. That's the opportunity of the range but you don't
have to have all of that and still very very nice delivery based on the logic
I taught you on Tuesday and the first lesson on the previous week's Friday.
Again there's that fair value gap and that's your candle that would be
considered as a ideal entry and the discount old low as a target right
there. So your charts would look just like this. In any open space like over
here you would just type in whatever important factors that you found
insightful about this example. How long did it take? Okay how long did it take
from the market structure shift occurring? How much time did it take to
get up into the fair value gap? That's real important. How long did it take
before it went from your entry down to your target in time? How much heat or
drawdown would you have weathered getting short? Now if you used this candle's high
as your entry point you technically could have got filled here but in here I
want to teach you to look at the total range available and in hindsight okay
because it gives you a framework to look for how these examples while they're not
exactly the same they don't repeat exactly photocopy of every single
previous instance of it there's a lot of similarities that you'll find that are
reoccurring and that's the important factor to train your eye to see it.
Remember the analogy I gave you on Tuesday night about the deer track and
being a hunter you have to know what a deer track looks like you have to know
what a deer track is to stalk it effectively. Well this is your pattern
and setup so you need to go in looking for it so it reinforces the idea that
you know what it looks like. All right we're looking at the e-mini NASDAQ
futures for Thursday January 27 2022. This is a five minute chart this is the
time frame you start with and you work down okay. So in the five minute right
away we can see the low to the high and we're looking for a high and go back in
time in your chart and you'll find what this is here but you have these relative
equal highs as well so that could have been a initial objective looking for
these relative equal highs to be taken out and does it break down give you a
fair value gap no it doesn't so it wouldn't even meet the criteria there I
know some of you might be looking at this well how do you know it doesn't
get you on a trade here listen to the rules I gave you they're very specific
and that's what I'm walking you through here that way you can see it's kind of
allowing the market or really forcing the market to show you its hand once it
does that then you can go in and act accordingly but you have to wait for the
setup you can't force it you can't think it's there it's there or it's not. So we
have old high here by solid quality resting above that and we have a run
above it once it goes above here doesn't go above it and break down and then go
down below that short-term low there no it goes higher so we just keep waiting
for a break lower to get a shift in the market structure on an intraday basis so
we have a swing low here it trades down through it on this candle here so you
know right away at that moment on this candle soon as this candle trades
through it you now have an opportunity then you go back into the high to that
candle slow and do you see a fair value gap it's right there okay this market
rallies back up trades into it here you can be a short seller there and the
market breaks down one more time we trades back into it and reaches below
the equilibrium price point now you have a couple targets here you could be here
here or in the imbalance and it hits all of them and goes a little bit further
lower
all right so that was quick and hopefully painless and again we're looking at
internal range liquidity and market structure shifts intraday my advice is
for you to go back through more data use the weekend that's coming and acquire
more of those examples that we can include them in your study journal next
week I'll work on targeting refinement and entries until I'll talk to you then
enjoy weekend be safe